[Música]
aquí comienza un nuevo episodio de La
Crónica de medio ambiente bienvenidos
hoy Hablamos de una noticia histórica se
realizó el canje de deuda por naturaleza
más grande que se ha hecho hasta ahora
el acuerdo entre el banco suizo Credit
suiz y el gobierno de Ecuador permitirá
que se destiren 450 millones de dólares
para proteger dos reservas marinas en
Galápagos uno de los puntos clave de
biodiversidad en el planeta en el canje
se cambió
1656 millones de dólares de deuda
exterior por un nuevo préstamo de 656
millones en otras palabras el banco
compró la deuda que Ecuador tenía con
otras entidades la refinanció a un
tiempo más largo y por un valor más bajo
a cambio de que este gobierno
sudamericano hiciera acciones concretas
para proteger los más de 200.000
kilómetros cuadrados de océano que están
dentro de la reserva Marina de Galápagos
y la reserva Marina hermandad este tipo
de canje no es nuevo existen desde los
80 y han tomado fuerza en los últimos
años en 2015 la organización the nature
conservan sí ayudó a las Islas
seychelles a condonar 22 millones de
dólares el crédito swiss hizo acuerdos
de este tipo con Belice por 364 millones
de dólares y un año después con Barbados
por 150 millones
Pero cómo funcionan estas negociaciones
para que sean rentables para todos
veámoslo con el caso concreto de Ecuador
tradicionalmente los gobiernos le piden
dinero prestado a múltiples entidades
para financiarse a cambio les entregan
un Bono como compromiso de pago y les
reconocen intereses Pero cuando la
crisis económica aparece algunas veces
los gobiernos no pueden pagar esos bonos
o sus intereses ante el miedo de que
esto pueda ocurrir en Ecuador los
compradores le vendieron tres bonos a
Credit suites que valían 1628 millones
de dólares el banco los convirtió en el
llamado Bono Marino de Galápagos por 656
millones con lo que ahorra el gobierno
ecuatoriano le asigna 323 millones de
dólares a las islas de aquí al 2041 así
todos ganan si bien los tenedores
originales de bonos perdieron un 60% del
dinero que prestaron originalmente al
menos no lo perdieron todo credi gana
reputación en las transacciones verdes
además tiene un importante respaldo que
no se había visto conjunto en esta clase
de acuerdos el Beat puso 85 millones de
dólares como garantía de crédito y la
corporación financiera de desarrollo de
Estados Unidos o dfc por sus siglas en
inglés puso un seguro de riesgo político
por 656 millones que cubre a los
inversionistas en este caso el crédito
ante un posible default una guerra o la
expropiación eventos que un seguro
tradicional no cubre y Ecuador por su
lado aumenta su presupuesto para
conservación Marina en una zona que es
vital para el planeta como nos lo
explicó el ministro de ambiente José
Antonio Dávalos
tanto Galápagos como la amazonía poseen
una biodiversidad que se ve en pocos
lugares del mundo de hecho Galápagos y
nuestra amazonía tienen especies tanto
de flora como de fauna que no se
encuentran en otro lugar esta
biodiversidad es la que tenemos que
proteger cada pequeño animalito cumple
una función que
merece una explicación científica
larguísima esto que nosotros hemos hecho
ha empezado por Galápagos porque es una
prioridad evidente para todos pero no
significa que los esfuerzos de Ecuador
nacen y mueren en Galápagos por eso lo
he venido repitiendo esto de que los
animales no conocen fronteras porque a
ver muy poco te serviría que nosotros
protejamos tanto el tiburón martillo o
el tiburón sedoso cuando está en
Galápagos y sabemos que viaja hacia
Costa Rica y hay un hueco entre que sale
de Galápagos y llega a Costa Rica y está
terriblemente expuesto esta necesidad es
a la que responde el el área Marina de
hermandad para para que puedan transitar
libremente estos animales ahora esta
esta conectividad no se da solamente
hacia Costa Rica también se da hacia
Colombia y se hace Panamá eso es lo que
queremos proteger Galápagos está
relevante porque allí viven por lo menos
2900 especies marinas de las cuales el
20% son endémicas es decir que no se
encuentran en ningún otro lugar del
planeta lo mismo Aplica para el 80% de
las aves terrestres de allí y el 97% de
los reptiles de tierra por ejemplo es el
hogar de la iguana Marina el único
lagarto acuático del mundo y Allí están
las tortugas más grandes que existen no
hay vano la UNESCO declaró este sitio
como patrimonio de la humanidad en 1978
así el canje no solo conserva uno de los
sitios más biodiversos sino que además
sirve de ejemplo incluso Tuvimos una una
reunión del foro de ministros y se
hablaban mucho de la necesidad de los
mecanismos financieros de hacer canjes
de deuda que fueron grandes que fueran
grandes no solo por un tema chiquito y
puntual sino grandes de deuda y es lo
que Ecuador Ha logrado entonces esa
necesidad de hacerlo ya existía había
mucho el tema de que claro los bancos
los multilaterales necesitan aterrizarlo
a las necesidades y posibilidades en
nuestros países y y esto demuestra que
se puede así el acuerdo podría no ser
solo en Ecuador el medio bloomberg
reveló que gabón podría ser el siguiente
Banco América organizaría la conversión
en julio por 500 millones de dólares a
cambio de que gabón proteja más zonas
del océano en 2022 se estimó que el país
haría el intercambio por 700 millones
pero aún no ha ocurrido si pasa al igual
que en Ecuador también habría un
beneficio mutuo de un lado el banco
estadounidense comienza a repuntar en
unos canjes de deuda por naturaleza en
los que el Credit switch es pionero y
del otro el país africano podría aliviar
parte de lo cerca de tres mil millones
de dólares que tiene en deuda externa
así llegamos al final de La Crónica de
medio ambiente pueden ver esta y todas
las crónicas en France 24.com nos vemos